let's see the number for zach allen that
started against the braves that we've
been talking about who's up against the
rockies team that is nine and 17 their
worst starts since 2005.
so here's mcmahon with the eight home
runs leading the club
not going again and this ball is hit a
ton to right center field and it is
going to take one hop short hop the wall
trevor is getting a green light he's
coming home and the throw not gonna get
him great slide by story what nothing on
the mcmahon doubled that's a good start
against zach gallon so an inauspicious
start for zach allen see if the
rockies continue to take advantage
three home runs nine driven in this year
for hampton
runners on the move
got the corner with a fastball and
strands two
two strikeouts in the inning for zach
gallon but the rocky strike first
diamondbacks coming up austin gomber
ready to go to work against the
left-handed hitting pavon smith
2-2 pitch
swag and a mess he got him with a
breaking ball
one two three first for austin gomberg
he is laboring here in the second inning
tonight now you got the big boys coming
up story
with two on and two out
now the first pitch on the way to story
breaking ball get to short right to the
right guy ahmed he throws to sink it
they get tapia coming into the bag
metal in the inning
oh we'll see what zach wants to do with
the bat corners come in for colorado
mcmahon from third he can't stray too
far from that bag though
gallon squares up
and gets it down they only have one play
zach moves everyone along nice again
second and third one out for the lead
off man it's pavon smith
28 pitches 20 strikes that clanks off
the glove of mcmahon no play at third
and we're tied at one
trying to make a backhand play ahmed
comes in
and it's a 1-1 ball game this is
starting to look a lot like last night
that'd be a fielding error on ryan
mcmahon a third baseman great base
running you can see dom nunez coming out
of the shoot i don't know where he was
gonna try to pick off i guess at third
base because mcmahon was moving that way
and josh rojos realizes there's nobody
at the base i could go second to third
outstanding baseline
chance for carson kelly first and third
one out
got a curveball lifts it deep in the air
for blackman in right here comes rojas
rbi for carson diamondbacks grab a 2-1
lead
two down and nunez at second
opportunity for rymel tapia who
is one for two
this pitch is reached for and sent to
right field coming on rojas he won't get
there he'll play it off the bounce nunez
around third he will score rbi single
for rymel tapia and the rockies tie the
game at two and here's trevor story
and this ball is well struck right
center field
and it is going to take a hop and go
over the wall a bad break
tapia would have scored as you can see
he was halfway home
stu cole saying no it's a ground rule
double so he's got to go back to third
that's kind of how the first month
for trevor story
squares that one up and instead of
getting a ribby out of it putting his
club on top
turns into a ground rule double
two in scoring position for rymac with
two gone in a 2-2 game single
undoubtedly will bring in two
and this one to left it drops story
around third following tapia home and
the rockies have a four to two advantage
ryan mcmahon coming through
gotta love these two out runs
[Applause]
out of the fifth inning for hampton it
was over two
hamson can run
as drummle
cabrera just moved over from first to
third made that look easy
boy that was a great punt by hanson i
thought for sure he was going to lay
that out for a hit but a tremendous
defensive play by as drupal cabrera
takes a hit away two down now for carson
kelly
that one out to right center and it gets
down here comes rojas he will score it's
a 4-3 ball game
second rbi tonight for carson well you
said it earlier bob that tag up first to
second makes all the difference yeah
they call them the little things but if
you do the little things right all the
time you're gonna win a lot of ball
games and josh rojas getting himself
into scoring position pays off as carson
kelly drives him in with that clean
single into right
so carson has now reached base safely in
16 consecutive games i'll bring up story
the pitch trevor drives it to the left
is it going to stay fair
gone
touch of all time trevor's story just
inside the foul pole as it drops in the
d-backs bullpen
a two-run shot
6-3 rockies he has two home runs
this season
since this one out the other way it
backs up blackman still backing up and
it's gone andrew young the smasher is
back
opposite field off gamber
and it's a six to four ball game
that one got out of here in a hurry
he's trying to get uh that run back six
to four the score
here's garrett hampson this ball lied to
left center field charlie's gonna cut
the bag go to third it's gonna
go to the track charlie turns the bag at
third coming home throw not in time
double for hampson there's your run back
seven to four colorado and he's got some
work to do with carson kelly carson had
an rbi single his last time up
carson kelly lines it to left
poppy is there varsha will tag
and it's seven to five second rbi
tonight actually the third now for
carson kelly
dom nunez double in a run scored in four
tries
this ball hammered high and deep right
field take a good look you won't see it
for long
grand slam dom nunez rocky's up 14-5
josh rojas who has single twice scored
twice leads it off
[Music]
josh rojas gets into one how about this
josh
they'll make it three consecutive games
with a home run for josh
[Applause]
here's one on the first double play ball
game over